porn is not just sexual that term  actually relates to torture like yeah  I'm saying like watching people  beat each other up on on Worldstar or  something you know it's like that's  called torture porn there's also food  porn  I explain that what's foodborne food  porn is like looking at really delicious  cakes and cookies and steak and so on  and you're like holy [ __ ] exactly  architecture like this people who love  architecture when they see architecture  I know I got friends they'll be like oh  that's porn yeah architecture yeah yeah  it's like uh that's like love like  dopamine fueled love for a thing  yeah we need that's beautiful I think  that's beautiful well I think as long as  nobody's getting hurt the intoxication  that people have  you know the worst part is like when one  person's in love and the other persons  didn't like  that's us right now  who's unlike no cause you said you love  Bill Maher and you like me  and I love you so that was no I I  actually love you both